and
final
chapter
have
what?
Stand
fasting
permissible
by
which
with a
types of chap
on what ex
is
things which
fast.
a person.
Not
can
long. Can
yesterday
Author
mentions is he says the final the
seventh and final thing that a person is
permitted to do while he is fasting.
[Silence]
So he mentions a few things.
Number one,
which is the meaning of
in the legislation of Islam, in the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam's
language when he says awak
it means brushing your teeth this is
what a siwak means now obviously the
word siwek is from a very specific type
of tree they would take the root from
that tree and this tree is what is
referred to as a misweek and they call
it a miswack because it is what you use
to brush your teeth and this is what we
see. However, any bristle tool that
a person uses or even if a person were
to use a rag or even a person's finger
to clean his teeth, this is
legislatively
considered to be what considered to be a
siwick.
So
the first he mentions is brushing the
teeth. The second he mentions is putting
on some kind of perfume.
The third he mentions is using lotion.
The next he mentions is alcoh and we
discussed in in detail
and al
are eye drops. So is placed on the edges
of the eye
lids and
is placed actually on the eye itself.
And the final is which is a any kind of
shot that a person gets.
[Silence]
Subhanahu wa'tala.
He cites as an evidence for the
permissibility of these things a lack of
evidence for their impermissibility.
Right?
He cites and this is a very
this is a very important detail to
kind of
understand and
a very important detail when it comes to
understanding
what is halal and haram. Understanding
what is permissible and impermissible.
When we sell you something is
it is neutral
means that it is permissible. You don't
have to do it. You're not encouraged not
to do it. You're not encouraged to do
it. It's neutral. It is to the human
being's free will. Whatever he wants.
This is called
this is permissible.
Now the thing with al- mub
is that al- mub is exactly the opposite
of acts of worship
when it comes to the affairs of our
dunya
things that human beings do right
we are not told what to do
we are told what we're not allowed to
do.
And when it comes to
worship,
we are told what to do.
And this is
very important to understand the essence
of this. If I were to say this thing
here, some of it is permissible, some of
it is is not.
Whatever is more
that is what I I would mention what is
least what is more numerable how do how
do we put this into words so for
instance if I were to have a guest list
let's say I I have a dinner and I've
I've invited a hundred guests
what would the best way for me to set up
the list for that guest a guest guest
list. Would I count the people that I
invited or would I count the people in
the world that I didn't invite?
Imagine that. Imagine I look at all the
people in Tucson. I say, "I'm having
dinner. I've invited a hundred people.
Whoever's name is not on this list,
they're one of the people I invited."
And then I I proceed to list every human
being that lives in Tucson except for
those 100 people. What do you think?
This is a way of doing it, right? Would
this be a logical way of doing it or
not? We list whatever number is less.
Understood? We list whatever number is
less
because what I understand from that now
is I have a list of a 100 names.
What I understand is
everyone
is not invited
except these hundred people.
So, so the def default of the residents
of Tucson is that they are not invited
and the exception is this list of 100
names.
Right?
So, I list the exceptions.
I don't list the default.
This is important because
when I say for instance,
The default of worship when I go to
worship Allah, the default
is that it is haram to worship Allah
except in the following ways.
And so now I list the ways to worship
Allah.
The five pillars of Islam, fasting,
giving zakah, making hajj, making salah.
I am listing
what the ways in which it is permissible
to worship Allah. What is understood
from that list is that anything that is
not on this list is impermissible. And
this is where we get innovation from. It
is not on that list.
So we understand that the default
position
is it is impermissible to approach Allah
with worship except in the ways that he
has deemed permissible.
So we can say the default position is
that it is impermissible to worship
Allah except in these ways.
Now let's go to the opposite of that. We
have worship. Now we have what is called
means what people naturally do. They're
not doing it to worship Allah. They're
doing it to exist. They're doing it to
enhance their lives. They're doing it to
these these customs of human beings.
People wear clothes, people go to sleep,
people wake up, people eat, people
drink, people these are things that
every human being does.
Islam does not list what to do.
Islam lists what is not permissible to
do.
We understand from that list
that the default position is that
everything is permissible
except what is on this list. We
understand it's very clear. So the
scholars surmise from this.
They surmise from this two points.
Number one, it is impermissible.
The default in worship is that it is
impermissible
unless Allah has allowed it.
And they have surmised that the default
in customs is that it is permissible
unless Allah has disallowed it.
And we can see this pattern from when
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala placed Adam
into paradise.
He said to Adam,
[Silence]
so
paradise is huge. It's gigantic. And
there are many types of trees and many
types of fruits and many types of
activities to engage in. Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala placed Adam and his wife in
paradise and he gave directions to Adam.
Notice the directions are given to Adam.
Why? Because Adam is the husband. He's
the one responsible for his wife. He is
in the position of authority.
And so he says to Adam,
"Live you and your spouse in this garden
and eat from anything you like
except this tree. Don't come close to
it.
And if you do, you will be of the of the
wrongdoers."
So what do we understand from this
command? We understand that everything
is halal in this paradise except what is
on this list. It was a very short list.
It only had one tree on it. Either one
tree or one type of tree. Right?
Do not come close to this tree.
Everything else is per Allah didn't tell
him what to do. He told him what not to
do. He allowed him to exercise his free
will.
Do what? Whatever comes to mind,
whatever you anything you want,
except for this tree.
This is the nature of our existence here
on this earth. When it comes to customs,
when it comes to what the human being
desires to do with himself,
he is permitted to eat and drink and
marry and
hunt and of everything that is on the
earth except and he gives us a list.
These things are impermissible to eat.
These things are impermissible to drink.
These things are impermissible to wear.
these things. So we understand that the
list always captures
what
is less what is shorter the list is
always shorter than its opposite.
So what is the evidence that
brushing one's teeth brushing the teeth
this is a custom right you don't have to
be it's not only Muslims that brush your
teeth right also
using perfume this is a custom right
also using lotion for your skin this is
a custom also using alcohol is a custom
also So eye drops and medicine in
general is a custom. This is something
that all of humanity engages in also hna
which is a shot. These things are
customs.
So when we approach something that is a
custom
we say the default position of a custom
is that it is halal or haram.
Huh? Halal. The default of customs is
that it is halal. When I go to provide
an evidence for a custom, I am looking
for something saying that it is
impermissible
because
originally it is all halal. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
he tells us very very reminiscent
of his first command to Adam. He says he
is the one who has created for you all
all that is in the earth.
Just when he said to Adam
So everything on earth is permissible
except and he gave us a list.
And so when a custom is brought up, we
don't look for an evidence that it is
permissible. We look for an evidence
that it is impermissible.
Right? Because the default is that
everything that a person does on earth
is permissible except
these things are customs.
And when a person is fasting, customs do
not automatically become haram simply
because he is fasting.
Therefore,
the evidence that these things are
permissible
is the lack of evidence.
The fact that there is no evidence
saying that these things are
impermissible,
that is the evidence for these things
being permitted.
And that is why he quotes the verse
verse number 64 of surah Miam in which
Allah subhanahu waala says
and your lord is not forgetful.
He is he does not forget subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
the fact that these things were all done
in the prophet's time companions are
using lotion they're using they're using
eye drops they are using siwek they are
using a
perfume while they are fasting and he
knows that this is being done while they
are fasting yet he does not say anything
about it and there's nothing about it in
the Quran. This means that by default
these things are what? Permissible,
right? They're not on the list. If they
were on the list, then we would have
evidence for them being that they are
not. Therefore, they are permissible.
Tomorrow, inshallah, we will begin with
the
optional types of fasting.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]